est-ce que cette mobilisation qui envoie
s'annonce encore suivi vous inquiète
t'inquiète la majorité une mobilisation
ne doit jamais inquiéter au contraire
elle doit être entendue une mobilisation
sert à faire exprimer des revendications
et des revendications qui sont légitimes
le seul enjeu que nous avons aujourd'hui
c'est quels sont les vecteurs pour
porter ses revendications au sein de
l'Assemblée nationale et force est de
constater qu'après plein de près de 28
heures de débats en commission des
affaires sociales la semaine dernière et
puis les quelques heures de débat où
nous avons essayé de pouvoir nous faire
entendre hier dans l'hémicycle et bien
les revendications ne sont pas portées
et c'est ça l'enjeu que nous avons
aujourd'hui on va y venir en savoir ce
qui s'est passé dans les musiques vous
dites une mobilisation doit être
entendue est-ce que ça veut dire que
c'est encore plus d'un million de
personnes dans la rue aujourd'hui il
pourrait y avoir un rafraîchissement de
ce projet il doit y avoir un
infléchissement de cette réforme le
projet a déjà pas mal évolué par rapport
à ce qu'il était au moment des
présidentielles effectivement nous avons
toujours été très très direct nous
voulons mener une réforme des retraites
pas pour nous mais pour notre pays pour
conserver le modèle social dans lequel
nous sommes nous étions sur 65 ans nous
sommes passés à 64 ans nous étions pour
une revalorisation des pensions
minimales pour les prochains retraités
ce qui vont être à la retraite et nous
avons fait un et ceux qui vont être à la
retraite plus ce qui le sont déjà
actuellement nous continuons à avancer
mais pour pouvoir avancer il faut que se
débat puisse avoir lieu le temps par le
Nanterre a commencé et donc il faut que
ce temps parlementaire puisse se mettre
en place
avant de revenir sur ce qui s'est passé
hier dans l'assemblée est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous comptez plus sur la
rue que sur les débats parlementaires
pour faire bouger le gouvernement mais
les deux sont liés je serai cet
après-midi aux côtés de toutes celles et
ceux qui se mobilisent contre ce cette
réforme qui trouve qu'elle est
particulièrement injuste injustifiée qui
voit une violence sociale supplémentaire
puisque les personnes qui se mobilisent
elles vivent aussi dans un contexte
actuellement ou il y a l'inflation qui
continue de grimper il y a eu la réforme
de l'assurance chômage extrêmement
violente il y a les prix de l'énergie
qui flambent donc un contexte social des
gens déjà extrêmement difficile et qui
voit dans ce contexte en plus le fait
qu'on va leur prendre deux ans deux ans
sur leur vie sur leur temps libre deux
ans pour certains dans des travaux dans
un travail qui va être particulièrement
pénible et donc nous à l'Assemblée on va
porter ce refus massif qui existe dans
le pays vous connaissez les chiffres
plus de 80% opposés à la réforme 80% des
actifs et plus le gouvernement parle
plus la mobilisation et le rejet sont
massives dans le pays donc nous à
l'Assemblée évidemment on va pas se
taire on va la porter cette mobilisation
et si le gouvernement est la majorité
pense que nous allons être tranquille et
sages évidemment ils se trompe je fais
réagir plus le gouvernement par les plus
alors cette phrase cette phrase ou alors
entendu en longueur de journée je pense
qu'on a bien compris vous avez tous la
même fiche sur ça je pense qu'on peut
passer aujourd'hui dans les vraiment ce
trajet par coeur donc c'est pas la peine
d'aller plus loin
maintenant on va parler on va plutôt
parler des Français effectivement
l'enjeu que j'ai aujourd'hui c'est que
deux points et sur la forme et sur le
fond sur la forme qu'on a vu hier et
assez inquiétant parce qu'en fait la LFI
sans s'en rendre compte enfin j'espère
sans s'en rendre compte se comporte
comme un cheval de Troie du
rassemblement national pendant qu'ils
sont en train de faire des claquettes et
vraiment de faire des claquettes qui
s'est passé hier à l'Assemblée nationale
et indigne indigne et bien nous avons le
rassemblement national qui en coulissent
sagement manches en pop-corn et
attention l'heure sagement et
tranquillement et donc ça aussi nous
devons être capable de le dénoncer ça
c'est sur la forme sur le fond mais moi
je suis très étonnée d'entendre que des
élus de gauche nous laissent entendre
que le système de retraite tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui à la panacée mais
pardon ce système n'est pas la panacée
mettez de côté si vous voulez le sujet
du financement est-ce qu'aujourd'hui ce
système est équitable est-il juste sur
les pensions minimales sur les carrières
hachées sur le sujet des femmes sur
l'ensemble des sujets de pénibilité de
carrière longue est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est la panacée
et donc ce que je vous dis c'est
saisissons-nous de ce texte pour faire
avancer ces sujets parce que je reprends
vos mots la violence sociale ça serait
de ne rien faire du tout on va revenir
sur le fond sur la forme Elsa aussi
évidemment je vais vous laisser répondre
on va commencer par la forme Alexandre
puisque le débat était marqué hier dès
le début par de multiples prises de
parole de la gauche à propos d'émotions
référendaire ces fameux textes déposés
par l'opposition pour organiser un
référendum sur la réforme des retraites
la gauche et le rassemblement national
avait déposé chacun leur motion
référendaire le problème c'est qu'une
seule motion peut-être discutée dans
l'hémicycle et c'est la motion du
rassemblement national qui avait été
tirée au sort et or deux questions pour
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
il y a le bonprivée il y a une bonne
privée d'examinée une nouvelle motion
référendaire une troisième motion qui
avait été déposée par le groupe liotte
liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoire et soutenu par la gauche hors
de question d'examiner cette troisième
motion ce qui a provoqué la colère de
l'opposition et surtout de la gauche
écouter
insoumise et la présidente du groupe
insoumis Mathilde panot
on sent la très bien dit elle a été
déposée dans les délais il n'y a aucune
raison pour que vous rejetiez cette
troisième motion référendaire si ce
n'est de rajouter encore un déni
démocratique au coup de force que vous
êtes en train de faire au million de
Français qui manifestent dans ce pays
alors faut imaginer que tous les groupes
d'opposition concernés par cette notion
référendaire ont pris la parole pour
faire des rappels au règlement ça a
retarder le début du débat sur la
retraite et se temps perdu par cette
querelle de règlement ça exaspéré la
présidente du groupe Renaissance Aurore
berger écoutez
40 minutes de perdues pour le débat
qu'attendent les Français alors oui
posons la question qui dans cette
hémicycle fait la courte échelle à
l'extrême droite c'est vous qui dans
cette musique le vote le plus avec le
rassemblement national c'est vous nous
voulons débattre et nous sommes ici pour
débattre voilà un débat extrêmement
agité un brouhaha alimenté notamment par
la gauche de l'hémicycle et face à la
colère de ses députés de gauche et bien
le ministre du Travail Olivier du socle
qui voulait commencer les débats il est
bien il l'a même pas pu s'exprimer
regardez
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales
mesdames et messieurs mesdames le
rapporteur général Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés
[Applaudissements]
plus de 45 minutes avant que les débats
ne puissent commencer que les ministres
ne puissent s'exprimer est-ce que un
débat serein peut se tenir dans ces
conditions sur cette réforme bah écoutez
il va falloir poser la question au
gouvernement et à la majorité qui hier à
la violence sociale que représente ce
texte a ajouté un déni démocratique
c'est bien la majorité une majorité
certes relative mais la majorité qui a
utilisé un règlement certes peu précis
mais qui la manœuvrait à l'extrême pour
permettre au rassemblement national et
bien d'être son faible opposant face à
cette réforme c'est le gouvernement et
c'est la majorité qui qui ont choisi qui
ont choisi ça il faudrait faire quoi
se taire ne pas écouter les millions de
nos concitoyens qui et bien dans ma
circonscription à l'image de ceux de ma
circonscription me disent battez-vous
défendez-nous demandez le retrait voilà
ce que ce que nous faisons et moi je
n'ai pas honte de dire qu'effectivement
nous n'allons rien lâcher pour permettre
et bien que ce rejet massif qui existe
dans le pays soit entendu la deuxième
chose sur les revendications et les
propositions vous avez dû participer
comme moi à la commission où nous avons
examiné ce texte pendant comment
pouvez-vous dire que sur la question de
l'égalité salariale qui est au coeur de
la question des retraites que sur la
question de la manière d'augmenter les
recettes pour pour les retraites sur la
question de l'emploi des seniors sur la
question de la pénibilité partout nous
avons mis des propositions donc oui nous
assumer extrêmement opposé à votre
projet et d'avoir des propositions
vous êtes en train d'essayer de faire
ici un débat que nous avons pas pu avoir
en commission des affaires sociales et
c'est pas faute de vous l'avoir demandé
c'est bien d'essayer de faire des débats
de fond sur les plateaux télé je pense
que notre rôle de je pense que notre
rôle de parlementaire c'est de le faire
là dans l'émission est-ce que nous avons
vu hier je le dis très calmement il y
avait de nombreuses personnes qui nous
regardaient il y avait des jeunes en
tribunes il y avait des adolescents
tribune et le spectacle qui a été donné
ce n'est pas des débats forts des débats
danse des débats extrêmement rudes ça
c'est notre rôle si nous ne sommes pas
d'accord et il n'y a pas de sujet mais
de voir ce qui a été fait avec le
ministre Olivier du soft qui arrive à la
tribune et qui n'arrive même pas à
parler on a dû suspendre et c'est pas
simplement au bout de deux trois minutes
pour rappeler au calme ça a duré des
minutes très très longues ou la
présidente de séance et elle brune pivée
vous a demandé simplement de laisser le
ministre pour voir s'exprimer et vous
savez très bien que vous auriez eu
loisir de lui répondre et bien ça c'est
pas une marque d'opposition c'est
simplement un problème d'éducation de la
de certains députés de la lsfi écoutez
il manque d'enseignants dans les écoles
je propose à Madame Thévenot d'y aller
je ne suis pas une entreprise
non mais simplement le mépris vous avez
raison et celui que nous voyons à
l'oeuvre de la part de votre majorité et
du gouvernement et qui est absolument
ministre de santé
concitoyens vous savez hier il y a la
députée Rachel kéké qui a exprimé très
très clairement et avec des mots très
justes ce qui est ressenti aujourd'hui
dans la population
je vous remercie de me laisser parler
vous demandez du débat nous l'avons nous
l'avons ici et donc elle a dit vous
allez mettre à genoux ceux qui ont tenu
et qui tiennent la France debout voilà
résumé la violence sociale que vous
mettez à l'oeuvre nous avons toutes et
tous applaudi les essentiels de ce pays
pendant le covid le président de la
République est venu dire nous allons
revaloriser ces personnels attendent
toujours la revalorisation et vous leur
dites aujourd'hui ce projet de loi que
vous allez les faire travailler deux ans
de plus et parfois pour certains et
certaines beaucoup plus
et pour les femmes en particulier dont
vous instrumentalisez la cause
vous instrumentalisez la cause au
travers de ce projet de réforme les
essentiels de ce pays sont ceux et
celles que vous mettez le plus à genoux
par votre réforme on va venir sur la
question des femmes un peu plus tard je
vous laisse répondre non moi je dis très
simplement j'ai tout à fait entendu
madame kéké hier et j'ai entendu
d'autres collègues d'autres bancs nous
les avons écoutés ce que je vous demande
c'est d'être capable de faire la même
chose tout simplement argument contre
argument parce qu'en fait ce dont il
s'agit vous avez tout à fait raison ce
n'est pas de vous ce n'est pas de moi
mais c'est de celles et ceux que nous
sommes censés représenter et nous avons
aujourd'hui vous l'avez très justement
dit vu notamment pendant la crise covid
que le système tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui n'est pas pérenne notamment
pour les plus les plus les plus
précaires les plus modestes les plus
fragile de notre système vous allez
mettre à jour alors accepter de
travailler sur ce texte accepter de le
faire je suis une parlementaire c'est
quand même assez cocasse si ce n'est pas
dire autre chose de supplier notre
parlementaire de dire s'il vous plaît
débattons en commission des affaires
sociales nous n'avons pas pu débattre
vous n'avez posé amendement identique
sur amendement identique sur a mais mon
nom identique pour remplacer 1% par 2 %
par 4% pour 50 3 heures rien que sur cet
exemple là et je pourrais en citer des
tas donc moi ce que je demande
aujourd'hui ne volez pas ce débat aux
Français
Elsa question est-ce que 18000
amendements
beaucoup de de leçons de morale non je
les écoute avec une forme d'amusement je
le redis pas de vous assure nous
assumons pleinement le fait de porter
aujourd'hui le rejet massif qui existe
dans ce pays nous assumons d'être sur
une bataille pour le retrait pur et
simple de ce texte qui vient je le redis
demander encore et encore des efforts à
celles et ceux qui ne font que ça se
faire des efforts sur le fond
vous savez pourquoi je minimise ces
espèces de leçons de morale au précédent
mandat nous avons porté un une
proposition de loi pour faire en sorte
que les temps partiels subis cesse et
qu'il y ait des sanctions fortes pour
les entreprises c'est cette même
majorité qui les a refusés donc vous
savez les leçons de morale aujourd'hui
ou les éléments de langage très bien
travaillé qui viennent compliqué que
cette réforme des retraites serait faite
pour les carrières longues pour ceux qui
subissent les temps partiels subis alors
même que ce même gouvernement cette même
majorité ne cesse d'être dossier et
particulièrement gentil avec les
milliards avec les profiteurs de crise
les leçons de morale il me passe
par-dessus la tête pardon on va regarder
parce que visiblement ils veulent pas
aller dans le fond des amendements on va
le faire on va le faire parce que je
pense qu'on y arrivera pas dans
l'hémicycle mais sur effectivement les
17000 amendements portés par la LFI la
nuque deux tiers deux tiers c'est
effectivement des taxes c'est pas des
taxes sur les effets de rente c'est pas
des taxes sur le capital c'est des
tactes sur le salaire sur le travail
juste donc il va falloir
cotisations
vous savez ce que c'est une cotisation
salariale j'ai travaillé comme vous j'ai
eu des fiches de salaire comme vous donc
je n'ai pas essayé de député toute ma
vie pourquoi vous donc je suis en train
le cotisation laissez-moi le finir à la
place de taxes et bien une cotisation
salariale ça vient faire quoi ça vient
grever le pouvoir d'achat des Français
pas dans 5 ans dans 10 ans à la fin du
mois à l'heure où nous avons une crise
inflationniste alors où effectivement
nous avons un sujet de pouvoir d'achat
votre seule solution c'est de venir
prendre dans la poche des français et
notamment ceux qui sont les plus
précaires et les plus modestes vous avez
même fait un amendement pour favoriser
les retraités les plus à l'aise
financièrement donc un moment je veux
bien vous voulez pas parler du fond je
comprends parce que c'est gênant à force
de parler à force de déposer des
milliers d'amendements dans le contrôle
pas vraiment ce qu'il y a dedans et bien
parlons du fond allons sur ce débat
n'ayez pas peur nous sommes là vous êtes
là ayons argument contre argument pas
pour vous encore une fois pour celles et
ceux qui nous regardent mais aussi pour
celles et ceux que vous allez entendre
en manifestation aujourd'hui comme vous
l'avez fait la semaine dernière et la
semaine d'avant l'enjeu aujourd'hui
c'est de faire en sorte que ces
manifestations puissent faire porter des
revendications au sein de l'hémicycle
pour télé
les revendications elles sont claires
dans la rue peut-être que si vous y
étiez vous les verrez et donc c'est le
refus le refus dès l'allongement non je
vous remercie le refus de l'allongement
de la durée du travail voilà voilà ce
qui est demandé à la retraite voilà ce
qui est demandé mais vous savez oui ils
ont envie d'avoir une retraite ils ont
envie d'avoir une retraite en bonne
santé ils ont envie d'avoir des pensions
dignes tout à fait voilà ce qui est de
nouveau et vous le savez très bien que
des propositions nous en formulons
puisque vous revendiquez le fait qu'il y
ait eu aussi de la concertation les
syndicats ont formulé des propositions
lesquelles lesquelles avez-vous
retenues supplémentaires il propose des
recettes supplémentaires refusé des
recettes vous refusez d'acquérir des
retraites supplémentaires vous savez à
la rentrée quand nous sommes arrivés en
septembre dans l'hémicycle qu'avons nous
proposer une taxe non quand nous sommes
re-rentrés une taxe sur les super
profits vous avez refusé alors ça veut
dire que vous avez refusé
si vous me laissiez finir puisque
nous nous proposions une taxe sur les
super profit pourquoi pourquoi nous l'a
proposions simplement parce que
aujourd'hui il y a des gens dans ce pays
des milliardaires en l'occurrence des
très grandes entreprises que vous ne
cessez de favoriser par de l'argent
public sans contrepartie et sans
évaluation qui ne contribue pas à la
hauteur de ce qu'il devrait contribuer
dans ce pays et ça ne s'appelle pas de
la capitalisation ça s'appelle
simplement une autre répartition de la
valeur ajoutée celle produite par les
salariés donc oui il y a des
financements possibles sauf que les
financements possibles que nous
proposons ce sont des financements plus
juste car ils proposent une meilleure
répartition des richesses et ça vous le
refusez c'est ça que vous refusez que
celles et ceux qui créent la richesse
bénéficient de la richesse qu'il produit
je peux vous réalisez j'entends tout à
fait cet argument de dire que nous avons
baissé l'imposition sur les entreprises
je l'entends tout à fait oui nous
l'avons fait et oui nous l'assumons mais
de dire que c'est contrepartie c'est
faux
1,4 millions d'emplois créés en 6 ans
essentiellement des CDI c'est pas la
plus belle des contreparties celle-là
celle qui permet non pas de se poser des
questions de où on va trouver un salaire
mais aujourd'hui on se pose la question
justement d'augmenter les salaires donc
encore une fois il est faux de dire que
nos entreprises sont simplement pour
s'engrais sont simplement là pour
s'agresser elle participe elle participe
à faire en sorte que nous soyons une
société où l'autonomie financière peut
être accessible à tous et notamment
notamment pour les femmes donc sur ça
j'aimerais qu'on arrête sur le principe
maintenant sur le sujet du financement
je répondrai
tout à fait votre sujet de allons
chercher des financements ailleurs sur
les effets de ronde sur le capital bon
visiblement c'est parce que vous avez
posé dans vos amendements mais allons-y
et bien assumez allez au bout de votre
raisonnement et dites très bien on sort
du système par répartition mais on
rentre dans un autre mais le système
para répartition c'est c'est assez
simple je veux dire c'est c'est dans un
dictionnaire très répartition de la
valeur ajoutée vous savez le
vous savez le fruit mais accepte le
fruit du travail à gauche veut en finir
avec le système le fait mais simplement
vous entendez ce que je vous dis le fait
le fait en face de vous entends très
bien le fait qu'aujourd'hui l'argent
aille plus vers le capital que vers le
travail et pas poser des amendements
prendre de l'argent pour aller vers le
travail ce n'est pas capitalisation
c'est la juste rémusion des fruits du
travail madame écoutez vous avez choisi
par le démocratique que vous organisez
de faire une loi au travers d'un plfsr
SSR plutôt qu'une loi organique admettez
la méthode que vous avez choisie et vous
le saviez pas déposer tous les 17000 que
que tous les amendements que nous
voulions simplement parce que ce projet
de loi de finance de la sécurité sociale
qu'est-ce qu'il permet uniquement de
regarder sur 2023 et vous le savez vous
le savez très bien on va c'est pour ça
que vous avez choisi cette méthode on
parler d'un sujet sur lequel je crois
vous les débattre et qui intéresse
évidemment les Français c'est la
retraite des femmes ça fait partie des
points de discussion feront-elles
pénalisées par cette réforme c'est la
question avant de vous entendre on va
regarder le portrait d'une auxiliaire de
vie à Conflans-Sainte-Honorine elle
devra partir à la retraite à 67 ans en
raison de sa carrière haché Gaspard
flamand est allé la rencontrer
7h30 du matin le jour se lève à peine
sur Conflans-Sainte-Honorine patricia
est auxiliaire de vie elle se rend à sa
première visite de la journée il s'agit
d'Anna magie de 99 ans on l'aidera pour
le lever la toilette le petit déjeuner
l'accompagnement le rassurer voir si la
nuit s'est bien passée on donnera les
médicaments également
non non attendez prenez votre temps
prenez votre temps réveillez-vous
doucement moi je vais faire comme
d'habitude un peu le ménage non non
prenez votre temps réveillez-vous elle
sait déjà qu'elle devra attendre 67 ans
pour partir à la retraite sans avoir
atteint le taux plein travaillez encore
10 ans lui semble compliqué
le fait de faire des transferts de
passer d'une personne à l'autre m'a vu
qui baisse au niveau de la route ça va
devenir dangereux ce sera et pour moi
les véhicules les personnes que je
risque de rencontrer il y a trop de
contraintes on est fatigué
usé
alors
c'est la confiture à l'abricot c'est ok
pourtant Patricia travaille depuis 20
ans mais avant d'être auxiliaire de vie
elle travaillait avec son mari sur une
exploitation fluviale en tant que
conjointe collaboratrice un statut qui
ne lui a pas permis de cotiser pendant
ces 7 premières années de vie
professionnelle
donc elle n'a pas eu le droit non plus à
des congés maternité pour la naissance
de ces deux enfants c'est alors arrivé
qu'elle change de voix et devient
auxiliaire de vie au départ à son compte
ah oui je vais avoir une carrière hachée
l'aide à la personne et ben quand
quelqu'un meurt vous vous avez pas tout
de suite à remplacement donc c'est on
n'a pas de chômage pour un contrat par
exemple de 10h dans votre semaine donc
on peut pas s'inscrire au chômage bien
coupé
mais c'est comme ça aujourd'hui salarié
d'une entreprise cotisée pour sa
retraité plus simple
aujourd'hui assieds-toi merci
comme on avait pensé c'est un peu un peu
hard pour Patricia le système de
retraite reste dans son ensemble
défavorable pour les femmes c'est pas
valorisé la femme et
je vais dire l'homme voilà il y a
l'homme et la femme mais pour moi dans
cette société elle n'est que la main de
l'homme
et on la rétribue à la retraite pour la
valeur de la main et pas pour l'être
entier qui a mis au monde voilà
en 2021 les pensions de retraite pour
les hommes étaient supérieurs de 40% à
celle des femmes
de Patricia quelle réponse vous pouvez
leur apporter elle va justement c'est ça
qu'on doit pouvoir répondre c'est à ça
qu'on doit aujourd'hui pouvoir
s'attacher de répondre au sein de
l'Assemblée nationale nous devons
pouvoir apporter une réponse à Patricia
sur le sujet des carrières hachées elle
le dit très justement elle en est la
victime dans le système actuel
répondons-y pour corriger cet effet-là
vous parliez aussi dans votre reportage
des pensions minimales qui sont en
général les femmes pour 40% et bien nous
proposons effectivement de travailler ce
sujet parce que c'est profondément les
femmes qui sont touchées par ce par
cette précarité au moment de la retraite
donc ce que je dis très simple c'est
nous entendons Patricia comme d'autres
en réalité nous devons avoir à coeur de
répondre à leurs problématiques pas dans
deux ans pas dans trois ans mais dès
cette année
est-ce que le système actuel est déjà
injuste pour les femmes d'abord à la
retraite c'est rappelé dans dans le
reportage les femmes touchent en moyenne
40% de moins que les hommes à la
retraite l'écart se réduit un peu au
moment des pensions de réversion mais
très clairement c'est le miroir
grossissant des inégalités dans l'emploi
donc c'est bien là qu'il faut agir au
moment de l'emploi sur les inégaux sur
l'inégalité salariale qui persiste
environ de 25% sur les carrières hachées
incomplètes sur le temps partiel subit
j'en parlais précédemment donc c'est là
les leviers d'action d'ailleurs c'est un
levier d'action puissant l'inégalité
salariale puisque si on atteint
l'égalité salariale c'est 6 milliards de
cotisations de recettes supplémentaires
pardon dans les caisses de retraite donc
vous voyez sur la question de
l'équilibre du financement des retraites
l'égalité salariale est un levier
puissant qui le permet je dis une chose
sur ce que dit
toutes les réformes qui ont le reculer
l'âge de départ à la retraite ont
approfondi les inégalités hommes femmes
à la retraite c'est vrai dans tous les
pays européens et nous le constatons
partout donc le report en lui-même va
encore pénaliser un peu plus les femmes
voilà pourquoi nous y sommes extrêmement
opposés les inégalités pénalisent encore
plus les femmes que le système
d'aujourd'hui évidemment et en plus j'y
ajoute que la question de la pénibilité
pour les métiers féminins et le moins
reconnu vous le savez déjà la majorité
précédente d'Emmanuel Macron a retiré
quatre critères de pénibilité sur des
charges lourdes sur les éléments
toxiques etc mais nous nous pensons
qu'il y a des critères de pénibilité ça
fait partie d'amendements d'ailleurs à
ajouter et qu'elle concerne très
majoritairement les métiers féminisés on
pense au fait par exemple je pense aux
aides à domicile qui vont porter des
personnes plusieurs fois dans la journée
les personnes qui ont des gestes
répétitifs de ce type et ce n'est pas
les éléments qui sont apportés
aujourd'hui et qu'on a entendu en
commission par la majorité sur l'idée
qui refuse d'ailleurs le terme de
pénibilité vous souvenez le président de
la République vous voulez pas entendre
ce mot il parle maintenant on parle
d'usure non il y a une pénibilité très
forte aujourd'hui dans des métiers et
particulièrement dans les métiers
féminisés je le redis cette réforme elle
est une peine une double peine pour les
femmes elle va être défavorable pour
tous et particulièrement pour les femmes
je laisse répondre Christiane
plus les femmes que le système de
premier point déjà et très rapidement
l'ensemble des 28 heures de débats que
nous avons en commission a été
retranscrit en direct et toujours
disponible sur le site de l'Assemblée
nationale j'invite tout le monde d'y
aller parce que effectivement nous avons
parlé de pénibilité en long en large en
travers et non nous n'avons pas pu aller
très loin dans le texte parce que on y a
vous y avez empêché ça c'est un premier
point deuxième point et bien en fait je
me rends compte que sur le fond nous
sommes d'accord
vous le dit très justement ça vous
embête mais moi je suis plutôt rassurée
de nous dire de nous dire
qu'effectivement le système tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui pénalise les femmes
et faisons en sorte que la réforme que
nous proposons pour justement enrayer ça
et bien soit la mieux possible pour les
femmes notamment qui sont souvent les
plus précaires et les plus modestes au
moment de la retraite et c'est
inadmissible et donc c'est pour ça que
je dis allons nous avons la possibilité
dès cet après-midi d'aller dans le fond
après la manifestation bien sûr mais
d'aller dans le fond des amendements un
par un débat après débat argument après
argument non pas pour nous dire que vous
avez raison nous avons tort ou l'inverse
mais pour répondre à ces femmes
justement précarisées qui ont besoin
qu'on leur apporte des réponses tout de
suite donc vous êtes prêtes à supprimer
faisons les 64 ans on n'est pas dans les
mythique
vous dites nous sommes d'accord donc
j'entends cette phrase j'ai dit juste
avant que toute mesure qui allonge
encore le temps de travail
pour les femmes pénalise les pénalises
encore plus et qu'elle approfondit les
inégalités vous me répondez nous sommes
d'accord
vous dites nous sommes d'accord donc je
vous dis prouvez-le et
à mon avis de toute façon vous finirez
par y arriver et il nous reste 30
secondes
en permanence mais madame sérieusement
je sais pas pourquoi il y a cette
attitude il faut qu'on en dépasse il
s'agit pas de vous il s'agit pas de moi
il s'agit vraiment des gens qui nous
regardent et donc je le dis encore une
fois on connaît tous ces métiers
pénibles soit parce qu'on les a vécu
nous-mêmes parce qu'on a vu nos parents
les vivre soit parce qu'on a des amis et
de la famille qui les vivent ayons ce
respect c'est dignité de porter leur
voix c'est vraiment ce que les gens
ressentent le respect de la dignité de
la part du gouvernement franchement vous
avez foutez d'aller sur le fond vous
avez vraiment Patricia qui a demandé
courage mais du culot vous en avez ça
c'est sûr
de ce débat et on va suivre évidemment
à l'Assemblée nationale pendant 15 jours
d'abord on regarde
[Musique]